the fifth-century in Greece started off
with the Persian invasions and ended
with the Peloponnesian War and now we're
entering into the fourth century in
Greece and as we enter to the fourth
century thebes is the dominant
city-state but as we get into the mid
fourth century and especially the end of
it we will see that all of greece gets
dominated and then unified by the
makedonia pnes or the Macedonians and in
particular the first unifier here was
Philip of Macedon and this is a bust of
him and he's known as he comes to power
in 359 BCE he comes to power his father
was king of MCed on but then his older
brothers die he becomes it's actually
his nephew who is heir to the throne he
becomes regent for his for his infant
nephew which means he has the power
temporarily but then he actually takes
full control and becomes king of Macedon
or Makka Don as it's often pronounced in
359 BCE and what he then goes off about
doing is taking over most of the Greek
city-states and eventually he's able to
unify most of the Greek city-states and
you can see on this map here which I got
from Wikipedia this is a little bit of
information about the map you can see
how he expanded his empire over time
that remember 359 BCE he becomes king of
Macedon in 352 he's moving into he's
moving into Thessaly then in the in the
three 40s he's going into Thrace so he's
going into Thrace and Molossia and
malossi is interesting the king of
Molossia he's actually ends up mattering
his he ends up marrying the king of
malossi his daughter Olympius who ends
up being Alexander the Great's mother
and she's a pretty interesting character
as we will see a little bit she was part
of this cult that worships snakes is
believed that she slept with snakes but
he goes off and continues to conquer
eventually he's able to subjugate most
of the city states of Greece except for
Sparta and that takes us that takes us
to 337 right over here where he's able
to establish the League of Corinth it
was only called the League of Corinth
after the fact but he gets the leaders
of the significant city state together
in Corinth that's why it's called the
League of Corinth and they swear their
oath essentially to Philip king of MCed
on who they call the hegemon and what's
really important about that is he's able
to unify the Greek city-states
outside of Sparta and in doing so he
sets things up for his son
the famous Alexander the Great the great
to continue to unify Greece Alexander
the Great actually able to subjugate
Sparta but then more famously
he goes off to conquer the entire
Persian Empire and then beyond in his
short life and will have at least
another video on that but just to get a
feel for what happened at the League of
Corinth in 337 BCE I will share this
this oath that the various city-states
had to commit to and it says I swear by
Zeus Gaia Helios Poseidon and all the
gods and goddesses I will abide by the
common peace and I will neither break
the agreement with Philip nor take up
arms on land or sea harming any of those
abiding by the oaths nor shall I take
any city or fortress nor harbour by
craft or contrivance with intent of war
against the participants of the war nor
shall I depose the kingship of Philip or
his descendants nor the Constitution's
existing in each state when they swore
the Oates of the peace nor shall I do
anything contrary to these agreements
nor shall I allow anyone else as far as
possible but if anyone does commit any
breach of the treaty I shall go and
support as called by those who need and
I shall fight the transgressors of the
common peace as decided by as decided by
the council and called on by the hegemon
who is at when this when the oath is
made who is Philip of Macedonia now
unfortunately for Philip
this happens in 337 where for the most
part he's the first to unify the Greek
city-states outside of Sparta but he's
only able to live about a year after
that a year later we're now in 336 BCE
and he's in the old capital of the
Macedonian Kingdom which is very close
to Pella celebrating the wedding of his
daughter to his to his brother-in-law so
his daughter who is who is Alexander's
sister she is being married to Olympius
his brother so his marrying his daughter
to her uncle and it is during that
wedding that Philip of Macedon is killed
by Posse Gnaeus who is his bodyguard and
there's a lot of really interesting
stories so he's killed at the wedding in
336 BCE and there's a lot of really
interesting stories about what the
motivation for Posse Gnaeus was there
are many accounts that say that Posse
Gnaeus was Philips lover he was on some
level jealous and he was on some level
because another relative of Philip
affronted Posse Gnaeus and Philip didn't
go to defend him there's some narratives
that this was arranged
somehow by Olympius Philips his wife and
the mother of Alexander to put Alexander
on the throne there are some motivations
there because also out of shortly before
the assassination he took a second wife
which was his more favoured wife as
opposed to Olympius so there's a lot of
really interesting accounts and I
encourage you to read up on it but the
interesting thing is is after he gets
assassinated well then there's a bit of
a crab a scramble for power but it
leaves Alexander the Great or eventually
is the Alexander the third officially
but eventually Alexander the Great
becomes becomes the hegemon and he's
eventually in his short life he's only
twenty years old when he becomes king
he's able to as we'll see in the next
few videos take over all of the Persian
Empire and beyond and subjugate Sparta
so he further unifies the Greeks and
takes on the mighty Persian Empire